and George was a big inspiration for me
because I remember watching you
and I thought to myself I can't do
Mexican humor because nobody will ever
be as good as George
so I don't want to compete with George I
don't want to do my mom my dad you know
the Mexican humor because this
[__] covered everything you did
so he inspired me to go I'm not doing
that because I can't [__] touch this
guy
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez
Paul
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of Super Bowl 57 has all
your Super Bowl action that you need
download DraftKings Sportsbook app and
use code OMG hi new customers can bet
five dollars on Super Bowl 57 and get
200 and bonus bets instantly only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with the code OMG
hi minimum age and eligibility
restrictions applied that means these
dudes they go by the letter of the law
Boyden Ohio see show notes for details
does it matter how much money you've
been I think if you bet five dollars
five dollars and you win winning is
winning that's really what it's about
it never worked out for I was just
seventh grade I was already this big
you were oh yeah I was I was that kid
mustache the whole [__] thing oh [__]
fine
there was a guy that uh
Enrique Hernandez his dad
his dad owned the gas station on uh
Sacramento Mission and
and Laurel Canyon Enrique was a fourth
grade the [__] had a beard
[__] me I swear to God
hey what are you doing here we already
had the gas station hands whether you
couldn't clean them because his dad
always had him working the oil is [__]
is like a beard Enrique
he would come with a [__] Texaco
shirt with a certain weekend and we're
like Fast [__] bass because I'm
[__] working on [__] 11 years
of Transmissions you're like [__] that
[__]
man I wonder what Enrique is doing he
probably owns a dealership [__]
illness you know I saw a little uh on
the internet the other day a little you
drink or not I guess I'll have one with
you what is it but I don't drink beer
but I'll try it I'm interested I don't
drink beer either [__] Gill's got me
all [__]
up down I'll retired
I saw some kid the kid couldn't have
been three four months years old already
had [__] long ass hair right here
hair like this looked like a freak I
told my wife I had a shot the [__]
kid I'd have thought it was a devil how
old was he he was only about two months
two three and long [__] hair all over
his legs all right we're gonna probably
lose the part where Gill wants to shoot
a two-month-old yeah cut that cut the
there's two-year-olds there's two months
old that get shot and that's pretty good
dude yeah is it
it's good thank you I thought that's the
only place I drink beer I thought I was
gonna have to lie to you I'm like [__]
yeah [__] are we rolling all right
uh what else what have you been doing uh
not that I I lectured at a winery the
other day it was good it was fun so it
was good it was good so Steve has been a
comedian for
did you start before you only 20 uh 20
21 years I met you at the Addison Improv
in 2000 oh when I was working the door
there
wow you worked the door I didn't
but you were a comedian already though
yeah I was already doing stand up trying
to trying to get my way okay and by the
way so so let me brag about you for a
little bit no don't brag about me
because that's a cop no everybody was
like are you bragging about me are you
saying that I kept held you back in Show
Business no no no
no so so back then you know we're
talking about two thousand
the only Comics that I knew at that time
and I and and I didn't know George right
I knew Mencia and I knew who Paul
Rodriguez was right the club starts
freaking out get ready
yeah but people are like get ready
because people say mancia I know I do
Raul men see it no I don't know it's a
made-up name everybody has that name uh
so so anyway
it's made up yeah it's like uh Clem
kadiddle Hopper like some Disney names
they're like you don't ever see one look
at them
Motors all right uh sorry so anyway that
you know I'm working the door the club's
going crazy at that time it was Trey who
was the gym Trey blue Trey goes my
favorite comedian he needed the money
George Lopez and I'm going George no
like he was get [__] ready this guy's
gonna show up and this place is going to
be a [__] mad house right so sure
enough that week I'm answering phones
and it is just 10 tickets 15 tickets I
need 13 tickets I need 40 I mean I think
that was trade just calling over and
over guys it was Trey same credit card
or something weird in the same [__]
credit card man but this guy walks in
you know wearing a suit never seen him
before and [__] I was rolling
and I was like holy [__] this guy is
[__] hilarious and to me it was weird
and I've been so excited to come on your
podcast because I've met you we've hung
out yeah we've never had I've never had
the opportunity we've never had this
opportunity to speak in face to face
stuff well and we've had drinks and
we've hung out but not like this so
my thing was I'm like how the [__] is
this guy not huge
annihilated the room completely sold out
and I'm sitting there going how is so I
wanted to ask you
because I know how hard it is for me in
this business
what was the first like was Paul already
on the scene when you got on the scene
um
well you have to go back to 1979.
I was still in high school so Paul Paul
and you know here's the thing
uh that we have to clear up first of all
when we talk about people on this
podcast we talk about everybody I talk
about myself we talk about your kids
we've said things but somehow when when
Willie Barcena was on who is crazy like
you know like he's crazy
you want to wrestle bro
and everybody gets all heard Paul
Rodriguez got all hurt but [__] Paul
Rodriguez and [__] with listen if you
can't if you can't talk about people in
this show everybody talks about
everybody in comedy and everybody talks
about everybody in podcasts it ain't
meant to offend you it's not meant to
send you also [__] uh
oh [__] yeah [__] everybody when it
comes to podcasts there's really buddy
that not only that we're all part of the
same [__] world I mean there's nobody
that that is like uh uh above above any
mention especially in podcasts most of
the podcast guys are talking [__] about
that themselves
so somehow I get back on Paul's mad and
and now you know uh uh Felipe's
partner's like hey fool to hit me
because I guess he loves Paul or
something like I mean this is some
[__] like like the goddamn uh Ryan's
hope they used to come on ABC like at 11
30. here's what I will say I will say
that thank you early on in my career you
know I would look at George and go hey
George help me right
and now that I've been in this business
for so long that's why I wanted to have
this but you said that I never helped
anybody which I I would have to say that
that's correct well but but can let me
go back I'll explain to you the reasons
why well so let me say what I want to
say is
now that not already
we got you know what because I'm so
nervous because I've never had to
address my impropriety
but now are you my feelings
my dad's most like hard work I'm like oh
it's beer that's beer no but but once
I've been in this business for 20 years
and and I realize how very difficult for
the Mexican-American this business is I
learned to gain a new respect would you
say it's difficult for everybody though
it's a thousand percent so so when when
I was young and dumb and I said hey I
wish George would help me I didn't
realize how hard it had been for you and
how you were trying to hold on to your
career right you know because when I met
you and you were [__] annihilating
the stage right annihilating and I mean
it's by no offense you did not have a
big career no I did not I didn't know
who you were I know I was I was very
Regional you know and it was one of
those things where
as I've gotten older I go well that's
why I was excited about this podcast
because I'm like I want to know
your path your story [__] we're
not here to talk about me I don't talk
about you because because I don't think
people realize
you know what they don't give a [__]
they do they only care the first time I
came down here no no I really didn't
even know there was a podcast
listen man you invited me down here for
a beer and I came down here for a beer
then I find out this is a podcast and
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me well I don't know we've
got some other badasses it's like coming
to a comedy show every week and I
remember Bobby Lee said right here and
he asked me he said did he get naked no
no he well he told me he said
[__] stop making me he pulled up
his shirt and he wiped his face because
he's crying uh this bonsa right there oh
you stop [__] made me cry I've
seen that guy naked too many times but
doesn't Bobby Lee have a career that
people thought Bobby Lee would be
further ahead can we say I think so
because Bobby Lee when he was doing
magic TV Bobby Lee's [__] incredible
oh super talented and then with a
podcast like Bobby Lee doesn't really
even have to do
standards Bobby yeah and he was doing
some movies but
yeah he's there's cats that come up man
and pop their head out and they go back
I mean so it's you'll well we'll talk
about it but it's tough so go ahead so
20 years ago so you know again you know
when I was younger I made the mistake of
of thinking to myself well it's George's
responsibility and and it's not your
responsibility and not only that to
realize now that I've been in this
business for I mean
I kill and I've been killing on stage
forever no TV show for me no movies for
me right I'm self-producing right so
when you look at it and then you think
about here's [__] George Lopez who
has a hit TV show on ABC
and had not had an HBO special NBC no
but I'm on the first one no the original
one oh yeah
um
today's Thursday Chinatown
[Laughter]
I'm welcome so
again you're not even on [__] HBO no
yet you have a hit TV show
uh was that the way guys were getting it
back then well I've had a lot of as I've
gotten older and been in this business
longer but is that what you thought that
maybe the from The Tonight Show or Drew
Carey made it from The Tonight Show
right Drew Perry Drew Carey was living
in his car and I both did The Tonight
Show and that [__] Tonight Show that
he did was like the one Freddie Prince
did were you were you uh Go Johnny
Carson calls you to go over and Drew
Carey was just if anybody is into comedy
and and and doesn't know who Drew Carey
is maybe because of his TV show was like
maybe 15 20 years ago or his Price is
Right Price is Right yeah that
[__] caught lightning in a
bottle at the time at the at the biggest
point in any comedian's career The
Tonight Show with Johnny Carson [__]
killed him and then got called over and
then I think was working on The Drew
Carey Show with Bruce Alford back then
it's deal deals
involving Drew Carey yeah the couple of
weeks ago it aired on Discovery one it
was uh his uh the girl that he had is
his fiancee while he was working prizes
right then she got murdered
and uh I did the discovery and Drew
Carey who's about Drew Carey and how he
loved her now he brought her can we ring
a bell every time that we talk about
murder we're back in Murder I love your
podcast man but you're always talking
about murder I said no we don't we're
going to bring a thing
it's a drinking murderer
so go ahead so and then what
who killed his girlfriend uh some guy I
don't [__] remember his name I just
did the show I just you know I was
aftermath I didn't it was my case
all right well thanks so he still it has
it has been adjudicated so he's still
going through court right now what year
was the year that you walked into a
comedy club uh June 4th 1979 Monday
nights at The Comedy Store on Westwood I
was still in high school
I was getting ready to graduate we
graduated the 11th
so the only comedian that was around of
any Latino descent was Freddie Prince
um at that point yes I hadn't seen Paul
nor I think Paul was already working in
the in the clubs but I hadn't seen him
yet until maybe a month after that
he walked in he was pretty uh Paul was
pretty good back then he was [__]
good well I mean so that's what that
that's what's crazy to me right so I
start in I started doing stand-up in 99
and at that point and what made and what
made you because Steve is one of the
most places where Germantown or Port
he's from Portland Texas there's nothing
there's got to be nothing there right
Refinery workers and cotton farmers and
that's it and that's small town you know
people that listen to this stuff from
all over the country like they you can
come from a small town and do something
like people sometimes they get stuck in
a small town and they want to stay there
they don't think that there's a world
out there there's a world out there and
and and what's your first memory of like
growing up in Portland
um I always tell the story and I think
we all grew up very similar barbecues on
the weekends men outside women inside
right oh yeah that's right
um all the men
you know such a small time I just
picture I thought you said well cow [__]
all over the place you know little town
yes you know they're playing with a play
with the animals yes what else they're
doing I would say Zimbabwe [__]
Texas he's agreed with me it's pretty
much like that like a Wild Kingdom or
whatever pretty much Wild Kingdom so I
remember one party I must have been six
or seven years old
everybody's in the living room moms and
dads and they're dying laughing and I
walk over and it's HBO Richard Pryor
and Richard Pryor Long Beach the red
shirt yep the red shirt one and I
thought to myself
whatever the [__] he's doing wow has got
my mom and my dad in the same room wow
and then so from then I would watch
Comedy I I that's the first time that
you saw a stand-up comedian yeah on HBO
and it's it's one of those memories you
know how it is it's etched in your brain
yeah I have that you know I probably was
probably like eight and I just remember
like everybody's laughing I'm going what
the [__] is going on
and I'm sneaking a peek and it's Richard
they were sitting around watching like
HBO HBO yeah and I'm thinking to myself
that's a job I'm gonna do that yeah so
then from then on and then who did you
see after then it was Eddie Murphy right
and then you know shortly after that Def
Jam started coming out right I'm I'm
waiting up late at night to watch the
def jams yeah you know and that's the
first place I had seen any Latino doing
stand-up was HBO
because Paul had done
um Sam Quinton
on HBO right then Mencia had come out on
Def Jam right but I have to I have to be
honest that's those are the things that
made me go
oh I can do it as a Mexican-American
yeah here's one here's one they're doing
it
well I'm gonna do it how would you
describe their styles to you let's say
you go back then back then how would you
describe
let's break down their Styles and let's
break down who they are and where where
they got those Styles can you because
you go back I go back you know Paul well
you know Mencia has this this kind of um
I always say it's the uh if you're not
laughing you're dumb
that's his that's his yeah you know oh
you don't get it it's because you're
dumb I'm so smart and if you don't laugh
it's because you're dumb and then he
would trick the audience into going oh
[__] I better laugh but he was kind of
smart though right he's very smart very
smart guy people don't realize that
Mencia uh got invited to MIT
people don't realize that Mencia is a
certified
genius is that true yes he's very very
intelligent
get invited to admit yeah that's what
I'd be saying you got invited to midday
that's bad that's good right yeah so he
did I didn't know that how come he
doesn't say that he I'm sure he said it
um but he's very intelligent are you
sure another comedian didn't say it and
he just he said it no
[Laughter]
um and then you know Paul Paul for me
seemed like an uncle
yeah to me you know matsia see more you
know oh this guy's a little more but he
was he was [__] out there mancilla
was yeah he was out there I remember he
was doing this thing called judge Carlos
yep or something like judge Carlos
here's the case it was great you know
um and then Paul for me was like oh
that's like my uncle you know what
you know you sound like
Thomas You Gotta Throw a tortilla yeah
you know yeah which would you get it
that's it that's that's you know I
worked with Joe uh uh Paul for um Jeff
Valdez in San Antonio poresito man he's
tired oh recently oh man he was hosting
and he'd be in the background what
happened what happened I don't know I
went over to say hi to him and he was
like oh hey you know he just seems tired
man how old is he he's got to be almost
70.
but but for me
I'm 73 yeah I ain't falling asleep yeah
uh Hey Tim check how old Paul Rodriguez
is on your phone you can't be older but
my point is I had people as a young man
that I looked at and said oh I can do it
right you [__] didn't
already Prince I would assume but he
died when I was in 10th grade um oh so
you weren't even yeah but did he inspire
you to do stand-ups yeah yeah yeah yeah
um let's see you know Paul Paul here's
the thing about both of them both of
them have
a lot of swagger like back then let's
say back then Paul Rodriguez was had an
attitude of
he was funny he was kind of smart it was
different
you know
68.68 guys
yeah you know what I'm 68. you know yeah
so
you know A.M
what there was a time when I think DC
cab was out Paul was really hot in the
early age that's when The Comedy Store
was blowing up The Comedy Store was hot
so me and Ernie went to go I would think
I might have performed at the comedy
store or not but I then I went up first
because I was 18. you could you had to
be 21 so they'd make me go first and I'd
go outside which is awful by eight by 8
30 it was jammed by eight o'clock when I
went up nobody was there and then I'd
leave three minutes and then I'd leave
and then we'd hang around outside and
then we'd hang around the back of the
room and one time
I Paul
had like a leather jacket with like some
feathers and I was rolled up
and me and Ernie were back there and he
was a guest and he went in there
and he [__] killed I mean everything
killed and we were just looking at each
other like
oh [__] wow and
and I'm gonna say this I I'll set it and
Ernie's not alive anymore but out of
respect for him we were leaving The
Comedy Store and I looked at Ernie and I
said by the time I get that good imagine
how good that guy's gonna be
and he was I never saw him that good
again
I never saw him that good because Paul
relied on Swagger and not Material great
improvise right but you're not gonna
you're not gonna survive being an
improviser you have to have some
material I've always said that that you
know the younger cats are able to catch
up because well George Lopez is now
doing a TV show right when George was on
stage weekend week out [__]
annihilating rooms
getting that material Tighter and
stronger and and well you took a break
from that to go do a TV show right I
didn't right that was my time to go
that's right I'm a [__] catch up oh
George is doing a movie [__]
ain't doing stand up I'm doing stand up
right right so that probably would have
only me or you thought about all the
other comedians all comedians period
right well because because I think it's
like boxing I think when you're a
thousand percent I think when you're a
boxer are you are you telling another
Boxer hey wake up at five so we can go
running [__] no [__] running by
yourself but at the same time right
these young comics
when they're young they look at you know
say George or even myself where I'm at
in my career and they go well why can't
I have that [__] you're a baby
you just started right I'm I was doing
the math today I'm on 11 000 shows
20 years eight shows a week 48 weeks a
year I mean
the [__] that's a lot starching
ugly yep let's go you know so when I met
you it was [__] George walked in
there
just laid the hammer down and I had
never seen anybody
tagged the way you did right and call
back [__] this guy the whole
show
something that he improvised
I remember you doing this [__] bit
about the cab driver pulling a turd out
of his ass to [__]
you're just improvising and you go the
damn cab driver smelled so bad I had to
pull a turd out of my house just to help
and then you were doing that and the
snake came out of the basket
[__] dude and that [__] was the
thing with the thing that ended up a
flute and a snake came out and I did the
snake but he would just snake behind his
head
Cobra came out of the basket
uh but but early on I I blamed you when
I should have been blaming the industry
uh does that make sense
well I don't know I don't know I don't
know I think you know what I don't know
man I mean it's like you know who who
knows what's gonna happen nobody really
knows nobody knows nobody nobody knows
so
um
with me or whatever I mean Paul had you
know normally AKA Pablo it only went two
weeks or whatever but you know he never
made it back right so when you're when
you're out there you don't you don't
know if you're going to be around two
weeks or 102 weeks or 120 weeks it's a
scary feeling will you give me
permission to say something
you don't need permission [__]
you're on another beer already oh yeah
the uh the analogy you gave of Paul
being an uncle
I will say this the first time I met
George in here it's gonna be about me
well I don't know
oh my God hi with George Lopez
I'm gonna refer to uh about Paul you
know leave me out I was asked you know
Bobby Lee says hey were you nervous come
down to me George and I said no
absolutely not he's nothing more than
human I was excited because he's a
celebrity I've paid good money at least
five times to go see him in shows I mean
I I thought he was great it was funny
and I wanted to go back see him again
and again and again I still like going
to see him
I never once put a nickel down to go see
Paul Rodriguez
and he was funny but he wasn't rip
roaring make my gut roll but wouldn't
you say George that that's because you
got passed up
passed out by what uh why you turned
into a stand-up monster see I become a
monster on stage because I don't that's
all I do right every weekend is me doing
stand-up for the past 20 years right I'm
not taking a break to do movie I didn't
break young I didn't break early you
know same with you you were in the
[__] clubs I was and you had to ER
back then there was no social media you
had to earn every single [__] fan
that walked in the door so if George
Lopez isn't killing that night they walk
out there and number one they don't come
back and number two they're not going to
bring other people
I had a high percentage of success like
I was like let me just stay in the world
it was just because because you know the
same thing with you is that
when you're going to places every week
you can't worry about the room every
week so your act has to be up to a point
where
wherever you go you know you're going to
be right down the middle and [__]
solid because it eliminates a bunch of
worry flying in to a town you've never
been to and you look out there and
you're like oh man I don't know if I'm
gonna be funny about this [__] and
if you're consistent you're you're
you're you're you're going to be you're
gonna rest easier you're gonna have
better time you're not gonna drive
yourself crazy with who's in the
audience and who's not in the audience
well what was even more trippy about you
too is that even though I had never seen
this guy
all these fans in the audience
were quoting him
like it was crazy to me that people
would be like right now right now and
then George would be like hey I'll get
to that [__] joke relax later later
right and and I was like who the [__] is
this guy
he was just so real my Swagger the stuff
you talk about your day you go to the
wedding they bring me a plate you know
what I'm not gonna go to their wedding
because she was a puta that was my
mother-in-law the one that was the one
that said uh you go I went to the first
two yeah yeah
I'm trying to get married with a white
dress with black sleeves but that was
what was funny is that he would bring
those characters you would bring those
characters back through the [__] act
with a little hole in the front and all
of a sudden you're like oh there's the
[__] Thea again from earlier you know
but but wouldn't you say that scrapping
in the clubs the way that you were is
why you were able to in my opinion
surpass Paul
Paul will always be Paul
but Paul has not made as many movies as
you Paul has not has has as many TV
shows as you Paul has not right done
what you have done
no not even close uh but um shouldn't
you be at the program right now what the
[__] going on no no I stopped going
there like 10 years oh see my bad uh um
but uh you know not to you know it's
just different different choices Matt
different things you know whatever
happened to Paul after DC cab and after
AKA Pablo I don't know
you know he had he had a HBO special
call I need the couch or some should but
he never caught
what he had the first time right but I
would say because
and I've been around him forever so I'm
not talking like somebody that that I'm
unfamiliar with I was I've known him for
40 years that he never worked he never
sat down and worked or or he hustled but
he never worked on his act well so I was
I I got to host one time it was called
The Three Amigos tour
and it was the most uncomfortable [__] I
had ever experienced in my life it's
true and it was Mencia Lopez and
Rodriguez Dallas Texas Bronco Bowl which
is [__] gone so Trey calls me up they
go hey they need an opener for this
Three Amigos tour go do it I'm like oh
my God I get to meet I got to be I had
already met George oh my God be with
George and Paul and Mancino oh my God
and [__] dude Paul's in one
Green Room George is in another mancias
in another Paul's not happy George is
[__] pissed mencia's talking [__] and
I'm like what that's terrible [__] is
going on
and then Mencia runs the light by eight
minutes walks in the room to George and
goes here's your [__] money and I'm
like what the [__] is going on well
later on I had found out that these guys
had to find him
every minute that he went over
because he would [__] do 30 minutes
because you're only supposed to do your
time
so how do you get somebody to do their
time if they want to go over is you find
them for the money that time they go
over it was the but why did all that
happen with Latinos because well I don't
know if it happens with everybody but we
weren't we weren't I mean but see it was
like Steven so
it was like you're doing a show with a
guy that has Steve you so you're like
are you happy to be in that show not
really
uh and then Paul
is that an ego thing for Paul
um I'm not sure I'm not sure but it
didn't go past whatever how many dates
there was I mean it didn't go past it
didn't go past uh I don't know five
dates it was uh we made some pretty good
money but and then so then you guys
split off and did the Latin Kings yeah
with chicha that wasn't much better and
then Freddy Soto and Paul I ended up on
that one so then I ended up hosting the
Mencia Freddy Soto got arrested soul and
um Pablo Francisco
and then you guys Alex romundo Joey
Medina Cheech right
and Paul did the Latin Kings right yeah
but you know we did we didn't we didn't
uh nobody got along so
with DraftKings Sportsbook Gil you could
bet what color the Gatorade is going to
be you could bet if it's going to be a
Touchback or a safety you could bet
um how long the national anthem is going
to be and that's why they're the Premier
Place are you ready for the biggest
Sunday in sports draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of Super
Bowl 57 has all of the Super Bowl action
you need new customers can bet five
dollars and get 200 in bonus bets
instantly
plus all customers can get on the Super
Bowl 57 excitement with DraftKings happy
hour special boots
check the draftking Sportsbook app every
day between 6 p.m to 9pm Eastern
Standard Time and 3 P.M to 6 p.m Pacific
to see what prop bet will be boosted
okay check this out
when Denver played in that Super Bowl
before the Super Bowl I had an intuition
that it was going to be a safety on the
first player and I didn't bet and it was
a safety on the first play and with
sports King I probably would have I
would have cleaned up huh
I hadn't I had a feeling
that it was going to be a a safety on
the first play WoW and it didn't happen
I didn't bet
that's why even if I would have been
five dollars
so any bet it's always good to win it's
always good you feel like you're winning
so if you don't have a lot of money
somehow the game is different when you
have a bet on it doesn't matter how much
sure you have an interest in it you got
money whether they say you have skin in
the game
John Holmes told me that one name
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code OMG hi new customers can
bet five dollars on Super Bowl 57
already and get 200 in bonus bets
instantly only on DraftKings Sportsbook
with the code OMG hi minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio C show notes for details
recently because of this thing that you
mentioned you brought up you know
they're all synthy though they do this I
had heard about the uh but am I making
it up no no no no definitely you know
what it is my daughter called me says
Hey Dad did you see what's out on the
internet you know out on Instagram or
something about uh it was Felipe
interviewing Paul and and but it was
wrong the problem is that Hollywood
leaves us crumbs
and then we're fighting over those
[__] crumbs like battles
I don't know if that's true you don't
think so I don't know what year are we
talking about
I mean look man I I
um every special that I have out I have
produced myself I saw that and that's
not easy to do it's not easy to do and
you know I'm proud to say that now I
mean and again you have that fear of oh
my God it could go away let's talk about
producing a special for people that
don't know what that's like I uh you
pick a place right my first special
because I'm from the Corpus Christi area
I walk into the arena with my wife and I
say hey I had a Showtime special that
did that barely aired I go what was that
one called uh Grandpa Joe's son okay and
that was a Scott Montoya produced
special they went to show times you make
money off that [__] no and then
owe you money yeah
lots of it now he's going to get mad
because we said he owes that money um
but he owes me money too for Latin Kings
of Comedy but that's different but
Showtime Showtime was like oh we'll
we'll play Steve Cinco de Mayo we'll
play Steve in September so I got like
two months of air time on that [__]
but but uh you went to the arena and
then what did you say to him I said hey
I'm gonna film a special here in Corpus
Christi and he said had zero [__]
production had zero money had zero
[__] I need the venue but you had to
have lights and cameras and all that
stuff right I hadn't had it yet I just
walked in gone Los huevos bro that's why
my company is called with lots of eggs
go on muchos huevos no good right that's
nice so I walk in I say hey I'm a film
special here and they go oh well he
already has a Showtime special the guy's
gonna do it I walk into Budweiser and I
go I need 10 000 sponsorship I'm filming
a special they wrote me a check that was
the down payment for the uh the American
Bank Center wow and then my wife goes
now what
and I go we're going to find a [__]
production company
and she's like who's going to pay for
that I go I don't know the door I guess
oh wow so we started you know putting it
out there and trying to get then all
sudden levity came on board and they
said well we'll produce it but we're
first money in first money out
I said okay fine so I go but I still own
it so I held on to 60 ownership good
yeah yeah and went in there we ended up
selling 5 000 tickets damn and I paid
everything out of the ticket sales yeah
and I walked out of there I had 400 in
my bank account buck and I looked at my
wife and I said this has to [__] work
put it on Netflix sold it to Netflix
still made no money because levity's
getting first money and yeah first money
out
nothing happens on Netflix I I tell my
wife I got to run a cruise you're still
on Netflix not anymore okay so I gotta
run a commercial because I know it's
good I put it out there
boom we go [__] viral that video clip
right now has 240 million views wow 204
what clip is that change my life what
clip is that it was a clip about my wife
coming back from shopping I got my wife
loves to shop and then she comes home
and she makes me play The Price is Right
and she holds up an item and goes how
much did I pay actual retail price and
I'm like [__] just tell me and then she
turns into an OP then she tries to do an
Auctioneer right oh my God I went over
to Macy's had ten percent got another 20
was like 30 I was like oh my God I'm
gonna get five fifty percent off and I
got it I was like I don't know if I
wanted I'm gonna get it oh my God I got
all of this right here for 200 to this
sassy [__] right here right that was
the bit great [__] viral and George
you know
I went from a fifteen hundred dollar Act
I call up the Improv I got it I don't
know what's happening but I'm going
viral can I have you don't know what's
happening [__] you know what's
happening but it was crazy yeah but I
didn't know if it was going to translate
1950s I don't know what's going on no
but I didn't know if it was going to
translate so I called the Brea Improv
they would always give me a Wednesday
night for 250 bucks they would charge
you like they would pay me 250. oh so I
called them up and I go I go robbery I
go forget about the 250 I want a door
deal
and Josh at the time who was a GM he
opens it up he goes Steve you sold 40
tickets last time you were here we
papered the rest of the room and I said
I'm willing to take the risk sold out
two shows in 45 minutes my life has
never been the same
God bless you never been the same
and everywhere you go that's the same
thing
I have not not sold out in four or five
years now what uh now we're doing you
know we're adding shows in 2500 seaters
um we're selling we're averaging about
five to six thousand tickets a market
now uh we're doing Oxnard this weekend
Friday and Saturday already sold out
um we're not going to add any more shows
because I'm at the point where I I just
can't it's exhausting I miss my wife I
miss my kids I'm not doing it he's never
done Stevens either yet I didn't sleep
at a steakhouse
it's a rite of passage
somebody's raising money somebody's
making money the comics are not viral
there
I didn't go viral that [__] Steven
Steakhouse you went to the doctor you
can hear the wedding next door
hey so so I gotta go my dad stabbed your
dad
when was uh when was that first special
what year was that first special first
special with with Montoya was in 0809
all right and then we we followed it up
with relatable which was uh 13 or 14.
that one went crazy you guys there was
that was Cup on 22. no no remember that
was me yeah that's just me and my wife
okay good so then after that I thought
to myself they're gonna call I went
crazy viral at that point I went from 10
000 Facebook fans to a million the one
the video was going [__] insane all
over the world I said Hollywood's gonna
call somebody's gonna give me a special
that call never came and again I told my
wife well film another one so then we
film till death on our own in a barn in
Texas a real [__] Barn
shot it came out beautiful went [__]
viral again
and then during the quarantine I go this
is a moment in time that I have to film
my experience
filmed it again on our own paid for it
on our own we own 100 that one's on
Amazon Prime till death is on Amazon
Prime
again nobody called now we're selling
out every comedy club in the country
we're starting to do theaters nobody
called me and my wife boom We doubled
down again we just filmed I speak wife
went straight to Youtube because the
game has changed you actually went to
you open your own channel on YouTube my
own channel on YouTube and and as you
know
through my podcast and my socials I'm
paying all my bills so my theory now is
why am I going to give my talent to a
streamer and give them my clicks right
when I can just take those clicks that's
true for myself yeah especially when you
do that if you if you have the numbers
you can run that yeah I mean five months
ago we put it up and we're at 1.4
million views wow on that special and do
you have uh do you have management or do
you have a manager or agency I'm a CAA
yeah and then my management is the same
managers they're music managers they
handle Pitbull uh the rapper yeah um
they handle like uh uh Enrique and and
Ricky Martin you know those guys
I was having a hard time finding a
manager that understood what I was
and what I mean by that is early on in
my career everything was
hey go on this audition right thick
accent
valet Parker right and I'm like man I'm
that's not me I grew up country as [__]
I'm my cars my vehicles don't go down
they go up but you are country right I'm
very country total you know I'm very
very conscious I mean like I'm from out
here horses we're like controllers and
[__] right I used to laugh I came to L.A
they're like Mexicans don't wear cowboy
boots I'm like [__] you've never
been to Mexico
that's all we ordered on Shadows we're
the original vacation that's right
that's right
you know why I went to Mexico to film uh
this movie and you forget that you're
from America and that our voices are
louder than everybody in Mexico so
they're like
and I said hey I'll take five and then
uh a Diet Coke the [__] [__]
look at this self entitlement this
self-entitlement [__] American over
there and then the guy put his hand in
the [__] oil with no glove or
anything
but that's why I get I get frustrated
George because the the urban Latino if
you will that's me that's [__]
awesome dude
was that you want a credit card that's
me on the credit card I need one of
those credit cards
does the money go from YouTube
[Laughter]
I've never used that credit card again
I'm trying to run rub down the numbers
you're gonna see him later
so yeah yeah so so he really did
something so so I get it I get it it is
frustrating to do good work and yet
um well the industry only sees the urban
Chicano you have to realize something
the only Latinos that have ever been on
HBO
are all from the same place
who are they it's you Mencia
Paul and uh
those are the only four that have ever
been on HBO as a special yeah they're
all from the LA area they are all from
immigrant parents they all talk about
the inner city experience so when you
got a guy like me who is very different
that perspective needs to be seen as
well and and when you're a black comic
you get everything it is to be black
from Katt Williams
to Chris Rock and everything in between
and the only representation that we have
is the urban Latino which is necessary
and we need it but we need a Steve
Torino too
you know there's this kid blowing up
right now this this Ralph uh Barbosa
kids blowing up and I'm like I'm praying
for him who is that because I'm like
this kid needs a pass I want this kid to
get the pass
kids blowing up George
huge and I'm very proud of him but but
Gil I'm not I don't hate on him I want
that kid to have it easy
I'm going to tell you this because we
[__] had it hard you harder than me
you said that kid is blowing up
I don't know who he is but
uh how where is he where is he from he's
from Dallas Texas
young kid very very young just did The
Tonight Show
um did one of those
um Latino HBO specials the kids selling
out everywhere he goes now and I think
to myself well where is it going though
you can't say everywhere he goes if the
kids going to [__] Wisconsin well to
the comedy clubs though yeah comedy club
in Milwaukee he's doing great yeah and
I'm rooting for him because I want one
young Latino to get the pass
well there isn't a pass I don't think
there's not a pass I think you have to
make you have to make
well I can't say they come to you per se
because
I don't think they do man like
I think I don't know how it is man let's
see how did it happen with me
um
I remember I don't know your business
but I don't think anybody owes anybody
anything a thousand percent you make
your bones you know you do what you got
to do and you unfortunately you don't
what do you mean a lot of times guys
that are that are not I love this too
that are not as funny or not that don't
work as hard they get a lot of breaks
right so when you sit there and you go
on stage and you're the one murdering on
stage and then all sudden this kid walks
on stage and he's just okay
and for whatever reason the industry is
like hey here's a deal here's a TV show
here's this that's not only him here
that's not only in comedy that's it
every day that's an everyday that guy no
I think he's really good and I think
he's I think he's a talented young man
you know and and I was a talented young
man you're you were a talented young man
if you weren't a talented young man you
wouldn't be here that's true right so
and correct me if I'm wrong but I don't
think you broke until 40s I was uh let's
see I was 41.
when you got the show where my show
premiered I was 40 when I got it and you
got Bell's Palsy I [__] got Bell's
Palsy when did I have Bell's Palsy did
you tell me that
no I didn't have bills I thought you
said you had Bell's Palsy from the
stress of the show
no okay Paul gave pause to his balls
that's what it was yeah no what
skateboard I had
where half your face like
I don't think so I had shingles but
shingles shingles yeah I don't think I
had Bell's palsy but but again
not stressful but it's stressful but do
you think that you were good enough at
27 28 no no
I agree with you I I was not in my 30s I
wasn't ready on on the internet I've
seen when you were young like almost
that 18 19. oh he's wearing the
cabarici's stuff young stuff those are
nice pants and you were nice it's funny
then as you as accomplished as you
became well would I be yeah you were
starting yeah I'm not condemning you or
blaming you I'm just saying there's a
major league difference from where you
started to where you well Mitzi Shore
says that in order to call yourself a
professional comedian that you need to
be doing at 20 years
that's her Benchmark
um so what I know who I know is it
in order to call yourself an officer how
long do you have to be on the force it's
[__] they called me a young punk but I
was working this case you know it
doesn't matter you know you make your
own bones eventually somebody recognizes
you what you do and then you recognize
it and until then obviously I've never
made an excuse I just keep working and
working and finding my way and and now
have a beautiful life I have a beautiful
home in Texas I have a beautiful wife I
have beautiful kids and the best part
about it is I make my own decisions
you know I do my podcast nobody tells me
what to say or do I film my specials I
do them when I want to film them and how
I want to film them and where I want to
film them so in a sense it's been a
blessing I'm very happy I couldn't be
happier
um
all right
okay
so you
you wouldn't you wouldn't like let's say
my okay I don't know if I say so
I don't know man I mean you wouldn't
want to have a television show
that's a tough one I mean that is a
tough one I mean I mean I get it Matt I
mean I mean I have to say like I knew
you back then and when I saw your wife
and your kids in your house I commend
you on that because I know how hard it
is to be on the road and be married and
your wife is incredibly beautiful and
incredibly smart and you guys work well
together and that's that's a great
Dynamic that yeah absolutely that is
great that it works it works for you
right
um
I think that's the show oh a thousand
percent I think I would love to do like
maybe you know what maybe back then
wasn't the right time right because and
by the way my wife is a trained actor
who went to NYU and studied at Tish
so my wife is a trained professional
actor and I agree with you I think and
what does she want how did you what does
she want to do she wanted to act so she
does commercials so let's talk about her
so she what the Titian is she wanted to
act and she was in New York acting or
she was at NYU and then we grew up in
the same little town Gregory Portland
looking amazing her dad comes up to me
and he says hey take care of my daughter
she's going to be in La for four months
and I'm like yeah I knew I was gonna
[__] her I didn't know you were gonna
hey thank you sir but I always say it
came out more like Allstate
she's in good hands right so immediately
we hit it off immediately we started
dating she had to go back to NYU she
comes back to LA to start her career and
she is also a Latina and everything for
her every audition was Spanish accent
sexy Latina wear a short skirt where you
know all of those things she couldn't
book a role and that's when me and her
teamed up and and I was like there's no
Latina producers I'll make one there's
no Latina directors then you're my
director for my specials you're my
producer and now I think that me and her
could do the new I Love Lucy
where we're an actual married couple
what's the name of your special with the
wife it's like I speak wife how did you
yeah they said you're America's husband
or something America's favorite husband
yeah that's the name of your show yeah I
love it I I agree a thousand percent and
and I think it starts in college I think
it starts like love story with Ryan
O'Neal and then you guys come out here
and you see that and I think it's Texas
and it's the kids and it's your life and
your kids a thousand percent there's
enough of a separation between you and
your wife and your kids are like young
kids and their wants are different than
what your wants right and then and then
you know and I'm sure that you went
through it too where I'm doing this
whole bit right now where we're very
confused on how to raise this kid
because we are so [__] privileged
my life is [__] out of this world and
how do I keep this kid grounded when I
mean he goes in my barn and it's a
[__] Mexican Chuck E cheese back
there I mean yeah pool tables and air
hockey and uh people you have all that
stuff in your in your house in Texas
you're born they're born and then my kid
goes I'm bored [__] you you're bored
right we had rocks to throw at each
other [__] off right so that that's part
of that you know what I say in my joke
I'm bored jack off that's what I think
rub one out and then the kid says help
me find my helmet get the [__] out of
here
George I think I think you're dead on
man and it is I looked you up and I and
I was today in the after work I was like
well that's this dude's show like
sometimes it just lays out and sometimes
it doesn't in in forget about me but in
whatever sometimes dudes make it early I
mean listen if Latinos are gonna make it
at all you can't put an age on us
because you can't say if I don't make it
by the time I'm 30 oh yeah
my darkest time was from 98 to 99 when
our senior went off and I was [__]
drinking and I just got married it was
[__] terrible
and I never thought that I would be on
TV much less [__] be on TV again 20
years later
so and and there's a time for everybody
has a time like everybody you know we
get caught up in like oh you know it's
[__] football season it's a [__]
new leap year [__] New Year's it's
spring and show business man it's
whatever it's happening whenever and
they're not happening and there is no
time to make it right it's just all
happening sometimes what if you leave
too early
[__] go back to where they came
from and you asked us to live and you
have to live in [__] uh Russell
Peters was selling [__] socks
door-to-door in his late 30s
and then he gets pissed because they
they leak his special to YouTube
I'm just changed his [__] life I'm
just glad my wife you know she's from
pvu that's Pico Viejo University and she
doesn't ask for much we made it we don't
act we don't need anything we're happy
and all this stuff even being with you
guys today and I say not only Jordan but
with you I mean you people are
celebrities are selling places out hey
I'm not asking for another this just
happens and since I don't have to look
for anything since I'm not asking for
anything
it's just but I've noticed that too
right I mean you know I did have a chip
on my shoulder and I did have this bad
attitude and I noticed that when that
chip went away and the bad attitude went
away then things really started to come
to me you know and and as soon as I had
the attitude of man I couldn't be
happier for George I couldn't be happier
for Al magical I couldn't be happier for
a moment I couldn't be and once that
happened to me and I truly am happy
then things started changing you know
what I'm going to tell you something
I did the same thing in nineteen
because I was worried about it everybody
but me I was worried about Drew Carey
getting the show Rayman you worry about
why is this guy doing that and why is
that guy doing that and it's too much
man and it's like eats you up you're
just like what the [__] is this [__] so
in 89 or 99 I was I was always a big New
Year's resolution person like hey let's
hey what's your New Year's resolution I
would make one [__] one I would make
one I'll try to keep and the one was
that I wasn't going to worry about what
anybody thought of me or I wasn't gonna
worry about what anybody else thought
they were disappointed I thought you
would make something yeah
that's never a New Year's residence and
then the one was and you know what when
I did that because you know my wife
would buy the [__] Inquirer and
People magazine and you're reading about
people and you're just like oh this is
[__] nasty and when I decided to not
worry about what people were doing or
not buy The Inquirer Now read about
people it was [__] like a drug but
it's hard it's very hard and uh after
that like you it things change because
the universe sees that you're not just
some [__] dude that's I mean
everybody hating you know so you know
this Ralph kid he did really well man I
immediately sent him a message on
Instagram I said hey dude
congratulations I'm here for you I wish
you all the success in the world and he
sent back he was like oh my God thank
you Steve Trevino I can't believe what
do you mean here for you like what are
you gonna do uh what whatever he needs
advice help whatever man I got his back
and they were asking for advice I just
hit him up so he hasn't asked me for
advice I don't give a [__] about us They
Don't Care Anymore yeah they don't
[__] give a [__] yeah we're gonna
tell them where to get ribs
listen these kids don't give a [__]
nobody's ever asked me what the [__] I
thought
and I've been I'm asking you right now
I've been out there for [__] ever
I've been out there forever but also
nobody knows that you know like when
you're in this purest I'm a singular
prayer I didn't have parents I didn't
have I didn't have any that I didn't
have my grandparents raised me I was an
only child I was probably I was by
myself so I was doing what I was doing
when I was doing the shows I was doing
what I was doing and
it's [__] hard every day is [__]
hard every day is not like every I mean
we got the whatever but in the beginning
but it's [__] hard if ratings and
this is a [__] this oh yeah [__]
hard that's hard man it's hard
in a sense it does but then also when
that show got canceled it was me not
everybody else it was me that got
carried it yeah because of my name so
they're all like hey what happened to
your shop
it's like I went in the syndication
nobody's ever done that
by the way didn't Nick at night to me is
what really blew you up that's true you
know I mean if I was on my [__] TV
every night
and I was on TBS it hasn't been off the
air in 20 years hey that's awesome I see
him in here I go to hotels out of the
state I see him on syndication I see him
on the airplanes flying over there and
on the way back he's still up when you
fall asleep in here put my bed again in
your face
right there
[Music]
so what are you what are your kids but
you know what this is the thing
I think I think comedy I'm trying to
tell them a couple things
I think comedy became uh before
this one event nobody apologized Richard
Pryor never apologized to Eddie Murphy
never apologized Lenny Bruce never
apologized George Carlin never
apologized nobody apologized for comedy
and it was the the line was if they
can't take it take a hike [__] them if
they can't take a joke that was just
somebody [__] you if you can't take a
joke
and then Dice Clay goes on Arsenio this
is what I believe and apologized for his
comedy
and ever since Dice Clay apologized
ER it it became a [__] a thing about
apologies nobody and he shouldn't
apologize he was a killer too and how
dare you say this and how dare you say
that and then we had to take
responsibility for that [__] but Chris
Rock never [__] apologized well I was
just talking to my wife you know on our
podcast we just recently had a comment
and they go well just killed my brain
cells and I thought to myself who has
[__] energy for that
who like to turn the channel
[__] or they just said that you
move on just move on and I mean I mean
what is that [__] like who thinks that
they're so grandiose I'm gonna let them
know that they [__] suck like what
kind of energy is that
who does that I don't know I'm not smart
enough my grandmother died in 2009 I
thought nobody did that after she died
but it's true so you have to live with
with people taking shots at you that
don't know you it could be 5 30 in the
morning they're saying you [__] suck
your wife sucks [__] you guys and it's
like I mean it really doesn't mean
anything uh well I've learned not to
give a [__] anymore I used to read the
comments and heartbroken you know they
don't like my comedy and oh my God but
I'm funny and I'm like well [__] them
I'm selling out there are some people
that think I'm [__] you know do you
remember the worst thing that somebody
said to you I'm going to tell you about
the worst thing that somebody said on
Netflix on Twitter when I looked at the
comments somebody had said [__] this
racist white redneck
and I was like ooh well first of all I'm
not a redneck second of all I'm not
white and uh I'm a little racist but
against people like you I think I got
you beat
somebody sent me on Twitter they said
this [__] sucks so bad I wish I
could go back in a time machine to when
his mom was pregnant and get a coat
hanger I shove it up
this [__] before you were ever
born
this is [__] pretty good man and you
were like you know what that would have
helped I was like I wouldn't have to
live this life I'm like Hey listen I'm
about you know I'm bad but I'm not that
bad like I was like wow you see a bunch
of crazy [__] especially around the
political time but it's not I mean it's
nothing
it's nothing but yeah once once I've
learned to like you know and and the the
more
Tick Tock has done
um crazy [__] for me I mean it's a we
got a video that that hit 13.8 million
views recently in in like a month which
one was that one
um what bit was it oh it was about
um from my Speak life where I say you
know if you're sitting on the couch
comfortably and happy prepare yourself
my wife doesn't like that [__] yep
she'll walk in and she'll go I go
speaking wife always comes in the form
of a question are you thinking about
going to the store I think speaking what
could be a topic a name for the show too
I think so too because everybody has to
you have to read between the lines or
you have to read you have to read their
minds
but also
they don't hold you as an equal so
you're in a relationship where you're
not an equal
oh yeah for sure right for sure and
you're you know your wife's a little why
was she like four eleven four four she's
five she's five three I'm six three
she's five three and that little
air conditioning unit
right yeah
[Laughter]
like when you get a pull a parking
ticket like that's where we walk up
like that little thing where you push
shopping carts because someone like the
thing where you put the shopping cart
that's it in the four by four the uh the
uh and she can tell you to go to [__]
you know Visalia to go get her a [__]
ice cream you'd go and come try to come
back without him how much time do I have
you see that's exactly what so I think
speaking every every husband Aaron are
you married and what does that dude make
you do run around to different stores
not do anything I just is that what's
his name
she's right now one of my kids the the
older one she went to the doctor today
got in a fire in the market she went to
the doctor on Tuesday she wasn't feeling
good they did the covet everything they
sent her home there take the take
Tylenol and then they called her up
yesterday and said okay you got cool but
you know you got the ugly [__] because
she's got now fever 103 fever she got
there she got back so isolator in her
room just put her in there they sent her
some you know we picked up medication
you sure it's not from her dog eating
the cat food I hope so I hope I take it
if it was from the Pedro I still want it
from somebody else and does your
daughter still live with you yeah well
she back she moved back during coven
because of the shutdowns and where she
was at she's back now they're getting
ready to go back uh so she's getting
ready to Hope
move back over here uh
someplace in Burbank Better Bank so he
told a story about his daughter never
mentioned her name never mentioned any
doctor that she went through just he was
around facts and then he goes oh she
lives over here in burbanks well no no
she's addressed
14. she's at home I started so she's at
home
my wife now has to stop everything she's
actually in a room my wife you know
makes luck does everything for her puts
knock on the door here's your food out
here she's still taking care of the rest
of the house she's still trying to make
me happy so last night I took her
a bulky of roses a lot of boy nothing
nothing just say hey thank you he said
what are these for I said just because
you're a good mom you're amazing you're
a good nana I mean I I save lives but
hey you're amazing there she is I find
murderer
I wasn't asking for anything there could
be nothing coming out of it I just want
to see thank you thank you that's the
way it's because I'm on my mind like you
said what did she say oh she got a
little tour I said thank you
I do I do a joke that hits so hard right
now where I go my dad won't tell me he
loves me oh so I go to my dad and I go
Dad tell me you love me and then my dad
says well why so you can take advantage
of me and then he goes you tell your
wife you love her and I go every day Dad
and look how she treats you dude
George knows
my dad never told me hey that's gonna
[__] tell that one George he'll be
telling that the next comic [__]
crime
my dad never told me he loved me the
night before he died he's not he's
passing away I cleared the room I said
and I never said I love you to my dad
and it was just a cultural thing I know
so I walked up and I said dad I got to
tell you something I grabbed a sentence
what what is it I said Dad I love you
and he looked me right in the eye and he
put his head on top of mine he says me
too yeah he never really said I never
said I love you
so is that cultural is that no that was
cool I know I think that's Macho [__] I
I just think it was but you know George
when I first started
doing stand up everything was about did
you feel alone when you first started a
thousand percent yeah but yeah brothers
and sisters I have two sisters felt
alone didn't know what the [__] I was
doing I didn't know where to go my dad
looked at me and goes hey man if you're
gonna go down this path don't ask me for
a [__] thing about that there you go
figure it out so but I remember how
about that don't ask me for a [__]
thing oh my dad died when I when I came
out of the army I asked I wanted to go I
really want to play football
you know as big I wanted to play
football I want to play at Rio Hondo and
my dad kept saying you're not going to
be a professional football player go to
work son go to work I said Dad I want to
go to college I want to play ball
and finally he said okay look how old
are you I was only [__] 20 years old you
went to Vietnam and came back you were
20. yeah 20 years old over two years
from 18 right I went in at 17. I came
out at 20.
and so that's I I come back he says okay
here's what a
last time I'll tell you he says my
friends tell me they're hiring a Ford
Motor Company
he says apply there if they don't take
you
go play football
God bless you you got the [__] job I
got the [__] job and I talked to the
coach out there and I told him I'm a
different I'm different now you know I'm
mature he says come on my dad wrecked me
man I told him I go haven't you ever had
a dream
and he goes yeah to be a good dad to
raise my family and have a good paying
job I'm living my dream and I was like
well [__] you then dude like is that
what he said oh yeah I never had that my
dad I never had it too much no my dad
raised there were probably he had about
10 11 brothers and sisters and he was
the father to all of them
his first father passed away his second
father got run out of Dodge because he
tried to play around with one of his
sisters they run him out of the out of
the town so my dad raised them then
there were seven of us
and nobody ever got uh they don't get
any more Mexican than that [__] I mean
my sister nobody ever got uh in major
trouble and I'm the only one at that
time that I was the only one that went
to college I uh because I wanted I
thought only rich white people went to
college I wanted I wanted to go but but
again we have to see it yeah it helps to
see it that's why your story is so
important that's why your story on TV
right now is so important that little
boy that you have from Texas
my kid likes him and my son's seven and
my kid goes oh I forget the icky boys or
uh yeah and I understand that his father
just passed God Rest his soul
um but my son is like Dad I know that
kid and I want to be a tick tocker like
him but my kid we need to see ourselves
in positive lights I gotta share a story
with you and we went when they were
talking about they were they were making
they were making a movie on the night
soccer 1989 just before I you know hey
Martinez and who else exactly a Martinez
and who played uh who played Frank Julie
uh Julie Andrews no I was gonna say
Julie Andrews how are you you're not
playing in a movie but I can't remember
her last name right now but so we went
down there were watching him filming
it's about my family you know they're
watching doing the filming and my son
who's about 10 years old then he says
Dad I want to be an actor I said you
want to be an actor
and we went down to watch him film we're
driving on the uh we're driving home
I said you want me to send you you
really want to be an actor you want to
get an agent you want to be an actor I
said he said yes I really do I said okay
pretend right now let's see how you
connect be a crying kid because your
dad's making funny because he thinks
you're stupid
oh [__] yeah and he I said I finally
made a deal with him I said I tell you
what I'll set I'll get you we'll do what
we got to do
and as long as you keep a b average in
school
I'll pay for it hey not even high
standards hey get a c Governor
after you're not gonna be [__] have
no [__] bees
you gotta maintain it with a flashlight
we're driving around with a flat tire he
ended up doing a couple of a couple of
commercials that's as far as he got with
the agency whatever they did you know
pay for you commercial for what I know
he did his hand a hand commercial and
something else and that's the one that's
gay
yeah but you have a son that's you have
a son that's gay right yes and you love
him like if he's a real person it
doesn't make a difference
I call him sonny boy that's my man but
when you told him he wanted to be an
actor I made fun of his ass
no Dad I said no no go ahead hurry up
cry get mad get back get mad at that I
want to see her how old was he when you
were like oh there's something different
oh I knew there's something different
early on 10 11 years old by then I could
tell yeah he was he when I came home I
had been two weeks
they go your guy goes how did you know
because when you were little used to
suck our thumbs
up
he was only about five six years old and
there was some show one of these stock
shows on TV when your son comes out of
the closet and she and she says at that
time you know my son was five you know
five minutes I had no idea nothing and
she just says what would you do if your
son
right now came out of the closet and
said he was gay I said ask him for a
[__] who said you said that yeah I
said that and she got pissed off
she got pissed off I said hey you're
gonna ask me a stupid [__] question
why get past my answer and then as it
turns out years later you know you ended
up coming out of the closet
no no I didn't that's the question I
reach around nothing needless levels
around the world I just told him hey
yeah or did you have a problem with it
no no not at all
when I came home there had to be a like
I come home I come home from Panama they
meet me at the airport where there are
two separate cars my kids and my wife I
get in the car and my wife I struck up
they had two cars the one for one for
you guys that one for him well because
there were better I don't know what they
were doing now and and so I said okay so
we leave she says my wife starts crying
she says stop I gotta get this off my
chest
and she's crying and I'm saying oh God
damn what did I do now what are you
going to bring up now and she says your
son just came out of the closet he's gay
now he's got to be you know 17 18 years
old
and you got to be older than that
there's got to be about 20. and I said
that's it
and she says yes I said okay
I said my son's not in trouble with the
law he's not using drugs he's got the
Kindest Heart of anybody I can live with
that right I said if that's it that's
all
I said that's my son I love him
and it's not gonna change anything here
we go anything come on here we go every
[__] time we have a podcast you're
[__] your own
you know the [__] you ought to you
gotta hey Steve how did the podcast go
I don't think anything and I talked to
the next day and I as long as you know
did you tell him you love them yes well
that morning the next morning he was
making eggs it was his birthday with
sausage
is there any more there's one left
it's not in the freezer the next day
where's the birthday you want to play
pop goes the wheels go down
that's not even a game sorry son I know
you're going to hear this [__] uh not
next Saturday the next day it was his
birthday and I had already bought him a
a card in the airport
my wife tells me she had to go get
another one because no no I I just wrote
a long message in the card next morning
wake up wife says hey go out there with
your son because he knew she was gonna
tell me that's big time man and she says
you gotta admire his courage man that's
hard to do he's in the living room go
over there he's waiting for you I said
no there's nothing different he knows
where I'm at
you can give them this card but have him
come in here if he wants to talk you
didn't go to him no hmm and she would
have you and you wouldn't know I
wouldn't put on my chismo still right
yeah still he won't show to him there's
nothing different why did you make him
come to you because he had something to
tell you and there was nothing different
going I still loved him he knew the way
I was hey you want to talk come on in
here and talk to me son
and so she the card he read it he came
in there
we cried tear gas we hugged and I just
told him just don't [__] don't grab him
in here wearing pumps in the house right
now you know and don't go on Jerry
Springer you know was that serious what
if he did well and I said
and do I have to stop telling gay jokes
and he said absolutely not so we have a
great relationship today that's great I
wrote a letter to my to my family and to
close friends saying hey my son came out
of the closet I love him anybody have a
problem
did you feel you you had to write a
letter to express yes not to explain him
just to let everybody know he's out a
letter to your son i s no that he wrote
to the friend I think oh you also wrote
to the friends and family I wrote to
friends and family hey my son just came
out of the closet he's gay my son I love
him I'm okay with it [__] off you don't
like it what did you put in there like a
pill you said here's this photo of my
son's photo here's this
every every time I leave my house my
wife loves George she says be sure and
tell George I say hello if she hears
this [__] tonight FTP
and I want to say this
uh and not even necessarily Latinos but
there's a lot of fathers that have hurt
their children because they've come out
and been and they come out that they're
homosexual hurt them right kill some
beat them up try to beat it out of them
they're trying to beat it up so do you
know that Lenny so Lenny Bruce but right
but you're you're look at your father
was the way he was never told he loved
you and then your father your son has
that and you accepted him which is Big
I'm gonna say he's big I want to joke
around but it's big because it's a
classroom because you know what friends
leave you friends leave you family
leaves you and you didn't do that and
it's the Macho you want to say it's big
that's huge man a lot of kids have been
hurt for what they what they are
sexually and that's wrong I agree I
think about their own family and their
friends so Lenny Bruce to get out of the
service said that he was gay right to
get out of the service they got him off
the ship because they didn't want
anybody else to catch it
that's how [__] dumb yeah people
think you catch Hotel like you don't
you were born the fight tried to catch
it a couple of times but things were
going good I always say that they were
nice two male incomes
too much I remember okay you're always
trying
no does he bring no he's now uh 40 [__]
44 years old and uh 45 years old
doesn't bring anybody you know he's he
is what he is but he does he does date
though he has I have no idea we had we
had a pair of Diaz or Thea that would
come home with her best friend when I
was a kid you know that's her best
friend that's and we're like is she
related to us they're friends and then
you get older and you're like oh
scissors I get it yeah so and was she
happy very happy I had a cousin come out
of the closet when I was living here in
L.A and it was one of those moments
where like yeah no [__] dude you know
because everybody knew him but I told my
dad I go hey you know so-and-so came out
of the closet in my head I guess there's
levels of gay to Latinos right because
he goes well does he pitch or
catchy pictures
I guess there's levels there's different
levels I know I say the picture of the
catcher yes
that's a class move man and that shows a
lot of intelligent Intelligence on your
part socially good we're close I love
him he's good
uh it's all right how is it working with
your daughter you're still making
cartoonist she still is he still is he's
making like a decorative control he
makes
you know like uh Roosevelt Greer big
football player he used to need a writer
my son does the same thing now he's got
a regular job but then but just as a
hobby
he does his [__] and he makes what look
like to me joggy shorts I I call them
banana slings uh he he does this and he
sells them and I mean he he'll make one
who's his model 75 to 125.
he's had him on the the walks you know
the the this what's the there's a big
show uh this gay guy that has his own uh
runway show
RuPaul yeah he's done stuff for some of
the models on Paul he's been in
magazines in Europe
he does there you go how is it working
with your daughter
uh it's good
it's good you know uh because
technically are you still the boss
yeah technically right your producer
executive producer yeah does she know
that sometimes she can't push on a on a
boss level no no she she's she's pretty
um she's pretty independent I mean you
sorry but I mean I would have to say
that you know she she was acting in in
acting camps in the summer which kids do
like when they're 11 12. she went to
acting summer camp and she was acting in
school and then when she got out of high
school she went to Second City she got a
second City so it's not unfamiliar to
her well I would watch her on Tick Tock
yeah she had a big Tick-Tock so what's
unfamiliar is the the the the idea of TV
uh every week but then you know first it
was the pilot so if you don't get past
the pilot it's over it right yeah so
then we got past the party then we did
the 12 and then the 12. let's see
honestly she had a couple moments where
she struggled a little bit with the
amount of work and with but does she
listen to you she takes your advice I
you know on occasions you've become a
better actor but yeah but I don't tell
her what to do about her acting I let
the director do that
so she's over and she and she works with
an act with an acting coach that's on
the show so she she does everything that
she needs to do to be prepared and
that's all that anybody could ask for
anybody I think she's good I think she's
good she's great if you look at it from
the beginning to now I think she's done
incredibly well and she's smart but it
also looks like you guys are having fun
we are having fun that's what that's
what you know for me when I watch the
show and and and of course
and I know that sounds weird because I I
know you and I'm proud of you and I know
that sounds [__] weird and I said
yeah it does sound weird but I am I am
proud of a fellow Latino that I've known
for 20 years yes that's true you know
somewhere um so I watched the show it
looks like everybody's having a good
time yeah and I loved watching the
[__] old cast
amazing looks fun and I could see it on
your face like everybody was having a a
[__] great time it was very emotional
for me because and Ernie's a valley kid
Ernie's from Texas he's from Milford
yeah
uh when when we did the table read for
the Christmas show Belita was there and
Valencia was there and Constance had
covet so she wasn't there so why not
that dude yeah so so we're reading the
thing and in the table
How We Do the whole scene where it says
well you know you don't believe that
it's really Christmas until there's like
10 people family members here so then I
go to the door and in the table read
just them two were there and then I had
to say hello family and I couldn't say
it I started crying right right and I
was like well their family you spent
years together I couldn't say it
took me I said it but it was rough
because you know you've been through the
whole war with those people man like you
said like military like when you see
somebody you went to Vietnam with but
also I was in the trenches with them
people but when it's happening you don't
see it until after and you go oh man
what a yeah I've been driving through La
I had my son right here at the hospital
um
is he all right he's great
my son yeah oh you had him yeah I drove
by and when you're in the moment you
don't appreciate it when I drove by
today I was like oh my God I had my son
right there you know to go back right so
that for you it was like going back to
oh [__] you were probably scared you
were nervous every [__] radio period
you're [__] your pants you're trying
to figure it the [__] out you're also
trying to tour you got every Mexican
comic in the world [__] hating you
true it's got to be hard all true
see if everything goes bad I'm gonna
meet this Gordo though yeah
we'll do a podcast together
you're past but but to see her but again
to your question I just want to make but
to see her
uh every day
and to see her do what she's doing it it
makes me
incredibly proud like I've never seen
well not really I've never been happier
or proud you saw these kids grow up yeah
and I saw mine grow up and and
to see her do her thing is really
incredible I never would have imagined
it's crazy that it's it's a become
Americana that [__] song
yeah right that song your intro song has
become associated with George Lopez
right what low rider Lawrence you
[__] hear Low Rider and the first
thing that pops in my head is George
Lopez
that's crazy
isn't that crazy to put that into
people's psychees yes and it's not just
me it is crazy that's insane it is crazy
it was my it was my ringer on my phone
and they're like no way come on I was
like what ring or else what else would
it be and then you get [__] because
they're like well they're not even
Latino well [__] I'm sorry dude it's a
great you know I'm gonna tell you this
war was not Latino but
in the music of that summer if you're
old enough to remember 73
it didn't matter if they were Latino it
only matters now like back then war was
all African-American guys man and they
were [__] great and and and Brenton
Wood and all those about those nobody
ever thought oh man those those dudes
are black it did [__] it's a matter
of music man that's what I love about
Freddy Fender man I just learned today
about war that bro they were [__]
George Santana
was Carlos's brother I had no idea that
that they were
they were brothers yeah I didn't know
that either I just learned that right
now they didn't talk for a while really
in 2000 a few years ago when they opened
up
the arena in San Francisco Santana did
it and Ward did it and I went over there
to be with Carlos and Jorge was there so
Jorge had a guitar he was telling me
about this all these Japanese guitar
knockoffs like got our fenders and all
but they're from Japan and uh who's
saying this uh Jorge Santana me and him
are sitting back Steve was alive and uh
we're sitting backstage talking took a
picture of us we got the guitar I'm
playing the guitar and he's like I'll
get you one and I didn't run the
knockoff not the good one but but he
said they're just as good but they're
knockoffs right but they're just as good
like the same guitar same guitar they're
gonna get you one and I didn't talk to
him after him when he passed he sent me
a message on Facebook which I never
changed I never checked Facebook but he
had the picture and had a guitar I got
you it was a sweetest message from that
night and he'd already passed ah so I
got the message I sent it to Carlos and
Carlos was like thank you for sending
this to me because I got to see what my
well my brother was like how long did
they not talk they were talking they got
it back together but they didn't still
see each other a lot just because the
touring are because
it was Carlos Santana so somebody the
guy that was interviewing him says you
know I had a brother to play the guitar
and he was my bigger brother he says
when I asked him for he said get away
from me kid you know you know he says
what was it like what and George says
that was the same way it was Carlos you
know Carlos didn't want to help him when
he was a kid
but I also understand Brothers like ah
yeah [__] off you're my little brother
and that's what it was but it gives you
drive too when you're the little brother
he's supposed to [__] you she gonna say
I'm gonna I'm gonna get [__] good at
this it's supposed to right yeah but
they didn't talk but also talking about
dice with comedy when kids stop playing
for score and stop winning and losing it
changed kids everything like everybody
got a trophy yeah changes they change
kids when you don't have to keep score
or
you didn't have to try as hard
participation trophy only you know in
sports when I play sports I never won a
championship but I came close
but not winning and seeing those other
[__] win and then you come in
second place or not make the play or
whatever maybe want to get better and if
everybody would have gotten gotten a
trophy back then I'm not sure it's not
the same feeling I'm not sure what the
[__] would have happened to us it's not
the same thing in something and I wasn't
gonna get that lesson from my
grandmother or grandfather but the guys
that not all your friends could be on
the same team so some of your friends
are on one team and some of your friends
are on the other team and you're on one
team and they beat you and then I had we
beat you or you're playing in the
championship game and they beat you and
you want to come back and you lose again
and you lose a cup of [__] and yep if
that doesn't I inspire you to do [__]
be better
not keeping score and everybody getting
a trophy will never do that never yeah
and my son I coach little league he's an
amazing little baseball player and he
makes a great play and I've always told
myself my face is not going to change
whether he makes a good play or a bad
play he's not I'm not going to get super
excited I'm not going to get super mad
same face so the parents come up to me
and they go man your son's amazing he
made a great play why don't you
congratulate him I go I'm not going to
congratulate him for something he's
supposed to do there you go he's
supposed to be good he's supposed to do
his job he's supposed to be great I go
but notice that when he does bad I don't
get mad at him
it's the same phase you try yeah hey
buddy you tried let's go I always tell
them fix it can you fix it right you
know and then now the whole team hasn't
has kind of all the dads have kind of
adopted that kind of atmosphere of just
fix it I ain't mad I'm not upset you're
telling me love him every day God bless
every day I squeeze him I never got hugs
I squeeze them I love them now when I
played in Sacramento Little League Mr
Martinez like a skinny he looked like uh
Slowpoke Rodriguez the uh Speedy
Gonzalez friend and he had he always
wore a suitable flakito so with your
grandma raising you how did you end up
in baseball like what would you be my
friend no because my dad should pay but
my friends play baseball so you just tag
along with them and and he would go he
was all good he goes come on you know
it's [__] across the park come on and
Louis will be batting a little through a
big helmet come on Louie how the [__]
did you find God and every time he would
go like this shut up I know what I'm
doing
how the [__] did you find golf I found
out for my friend Ernie like but I
watched golf on TV because I got up
early in the British Open and you would
be like what this [__] golf is on so
I watched golf there in the in the
mornings and I watched I just found her
from watching TV on the weekends and
then
um you'd see Lee Trevino and you'd see
Nicholas and you see all those guys
right Watson all those guys and then in
on Christmas day I was already done what
was I 8120 and he calls me up around 11
15 he goes what are you doing I still
remember I'm not doing [__] he goes
let's go play golf I'm like where El
Carrizo like dude we don't have any golf
clubs because I called over man the
Renaissance but they're not even open
they're open the rent is closed so we
went me and him just [__] it and we went
there was nobody there
and what happened earlier passed away in
uh in the last day so he introduced you
to golf he introduced me to everything
that I do back then he introduced me to
Comedy did he have a dad yes and a mom
and a sister two sisters one younger one
older and two brothers and the thing
that's amazing he was a big influence on
you not having a dad yes and also he had
other friends like he didn't need to be
my friend because he had other friends
and I was always the longest man my
grandma and grandfather and he would
come over and be my friend so uh in the
beginning he got me into comedy he was
the guy that said let's go to The Comedy
Store and then he got me into golf he
got me into uh guitars and he got me
into Richard Pryor like one dude I would
I don't even know if I would have found
those things on my own but he he gave me
the four pads that I'm still on right
that's crazy man yeah you got to miss
him that's badass yeah yeah yeah because
he's the homie from the homies the
homies that's my first friend ever yeah
yeah it's a trip because I wasn't
talking to him toward the end but also
he had his own life and you know he was
a little flaky man like but I think it
was meant to be like he I would always
wait for him to go to The Comedy Store
when we were 18 and then if he called me
and say hey man I'm not going I wouldn't
go because you're like no no you got to
come with me yeah I had to have somebody
come with me but then after that hanging
out by yourself dude and after a while
started to think
well what's gonna happen if this dude
[__] doesn't go with me I'm gonna not
I'm not going because because so I
started to go by myself and that's when
did you make the Ice House your home
I started going through the ice house
he was the king
he would have like they had shrines of
this [__] 48 sold out [__]
shows in a row [__] like that ice house
was like
84.85 maybe
and and I think it started to emcee but
you think that that's because you
weren't at The Comedy Store you were at
the Ice House kind of kept it I made I
made it to a point to stay away from The
Comedy Store
and to stay away from the Laugh Factory
and The Improv so I just hung around the
ice house and tried and tried to get as
good as I could be before I went over to
those places and when I did finally go
to those places I didn't go to The
Comedy Store but I went to The Improv
which is a tough room but then when I
went to the Laugh Factory I was killing
everybody
because back then they would do uh you
know I always say when I moved to town I
never felt racism in Texas it wasn't
until I moved here
I moved here how are you racist against
you you oh because I moved here and all
sudden it was oh great you can do
Mexican Monday at Laugh Factory you can
do Taco Tuesday at The Comedy Store you
can do refried Friday at The Improv I'm
like I just want to do comedy right can
I just do stand up I'ma stand up just
like Sarah stand up you know and and
George was a big inspiration for me
because I remember watching you
and I thought to myself I can't do
Mexican humor
because nobody will ever be as good as
George
so I don't want to compete with George I
don't want to do my mom my dad you know
the Mexican humor because this
[__] covered everything
good so he inspired me to go I'm not
doing that because I can't [__] touch
this guy
and George Lopez is George Lopez and I'm
gonna start doing my wife my life good
different because
and I tell these young Comics I'm like
bro George was doing that joke I watch
him and I'm saying they're punch lines
I'm like guys you're doing George Lopez
jokes that I've seen George do already
and George wrote him and was doing it at
a time when nobody was what about when
they make a meme and they use seven up
or a hot dog and a piece of bread I did
that a stand-up a million years 30 years
ago yeah right where they go my
grandmother didn't buy hot dog buns so I
said his bread is it's the same [__]
look at this George bread hot dog bun
she pulls it right it's the same [__] so
I also understood as I got older why you
didn't want Latino Comics opening
because it was this they were trying to
do you and then now you got to go up and
do you everybody that I used the right
or wrong you're 100 everybody that I
used
that was Latino or say you know of color
eventually started to inherit some of my
traits in the way that they talked in
the names that they used and in the
sense of their delivery and I would look
at uh Ann and I would go
there's another one because they would
have the same Cadence that I had that
they didn't have until they started
working with me but it's also hard
because for us I always laugh when you
know these these young black Comics they
go oh my God this young black comic he
does all these great impressions of
these famous black people and I go well
I don't have any famous Latinos to do
Impressions on yeah but George and Paul
that's it I got two so of course I'm not
gonna be a good impression you're a good
Paul hey you know what hey you know hey
sometimes sounds like I'm so tired of
George Lopez broy he is tired of me but
but it is it is you know for me I said I
thought to myself I will never be able
to do what this man does as good as him
it's impossible
I was born in [__] 78 he's walking on
stage in seven days yeah how the [__] am
I going to catch up to this guy but but
I think maybe I wasn't always the most
helpful individual back then but what I
have done is I've left a template on how
to do [__]
and then it's all at somebody's duty to
go and do it exactly correct and that's
that's the that's the legacy is I left
the Legacy for guys to follow the
[__] crumbs that that the path that
was there they crack the door it's our
job to kick it open go get it don't
blame me for what he didn't give me get
up off your ass and do it well it's that
simple you had to do it without somebody
uh leading you and and now it's but it
is but it is up to us to to you know the
Ralph babosas of the world to turn
around and go hey man I want to make my
the path for you but nobody don't say
that [__] is well he's saying
his name man look I think he's great and
I'm I'm doing it wrong I'm doing exactly
what what I'm preaching is what do you
mean can we bring this kid up right have
you heard of him
okay is it wrong for me to say why do
you keep bringing his name up nobody
knows who he is
[Laughter]
okay I mean but you you look out for
yourself that's what we look out for
yourself but I also want to look out for
others and and I also want to make the
path I don't think that's a right you
know I don't think that's the right I
don't think that's the right thing
I look I look out for myself and my
family of course but I also want to make
the path easier for the next guy you
know what I think that's
you don't think so I don't no I I really
don't you made the path you've got to
secure that path you're not helping him
if you're making the path easier for him
he's got to make his own path he's got
to make it right I don't know who he is
and I don't want to make him suffer but
you're not doing them anything by making
it easier I disagree I mean you look at
Richard Pryor who who championed Eddie
Murphy who you know when Eddie Murphy
walks into I don't think he did he did
and when Eddie Murphy walks into ABC and
says hey that's [__] earthquake I
think he's [__] great he needs an
opportunity I don't see anything wrong
with that I I think that that's a good
look and I think that it helps
um you know the you put you putting me
on this show helps me
but also if you don't deliver I can't
help you I don't disagree of course like
if you can deliver work I don't help
those that don't help themselves
right yeah yeah and that becomes the
thing but like I said I don't help those
that don't help themselves I'm not you
know I'm looking for for that young guy
that's working hard that's trying to
make it if I can get them to open it but
you're [__] trying to make it like
why are you trying to help with some
dude that's trying to make it like you
you need to make it I made it Life's
good
so you don't want to go any higher than
where you are I want to go higher of
course and I'm going to continue to go
higher I'm not in the business but if
you want to go higher then I would
believe just like in anything every
other aspect well if you're not in the
business
you got to concentrate on making
yourself you want to go higher look at
that doesn't concentrate on yourself
making yourself higher of course and and
I'm on stage every single day getting
better getting stronger getting funnier
I will say something about you first of
all I don't think you should be worried
about anybody else especially uh
especially somebody who's not in the
building
Jeremy barbasol as his name I don't know
I don't mean any disrespect but I don't
know who he is uh um but also
when they
when they come I think I think you have
to prepare for the future and not expect
somebody to come and get it like if you
say hey I have I have a treatment for me
and my wife or parents our kids are you
know they don't we gave them too much
already they're young how are we going
to prepare them for the real life and
you and your wife do this thing it's uh
I speak wife
I I like I speak wife
as a title I think it's a great title
yep I love and you got friends you work
in whatever is is common I wrote I wrote
a script I'll send it all right it is uh
it is me and my wife working together
and I am a marriage therapist and she is
my second do you think that's the right
profession for you as a as a as an actor
it's hard because you know I think you
have to be generally around something
right well I and and again I trust your
expertise as well when they when they
came to me
for the first show and they said well
what are you what are you going to do
what's the show going to be about and I
said that's how simple that's how I've
worked with my grandmother at RCA became
Sperry in Van Nuys right
I worked with my grandmother worked
there forever and she got me a job there
and we made that uh Powers Brothers
Aviation they made landing gear right we
went to an aviation place in Sylmar and
saw a real place saw a guy that was a
boss saw the guy the workers and then
and then we made that the place where I
worked at an airplane parts place and I
worked with my mom and the pilot was
that my mom was checking in her friends
which my grandmother would do checking
her friends punching her friends right I
remember like and I'm like what are you
doing punching in my friends but they're
not here yet shut up and uh you have a
decision I became the boss or they moved
me up not to the bus but I became a
supervisor whatever and the first day is
was the day where
I had to be a supervisor for everybody I
worked with and my mom was punching in
everybody and then the the bosses came
to me and said you have to fire your mom
right just to see if I was management
material and at the end of the show they
said I fired you she said I quit I fired
you I quit and the whole dynamic was
the truth was it was the it just laid
out that we worked together this and
that this and that and then Bruce came
up with because we were stuck for like a
week what's the end and Bruce came up
with you have to fire your mom and and
they tested you to see if you have the
balls to do it and I did it and then she
said she quit then we got a big fight
that was the end of the pilot but that
that worked right and and even we used
to go to 7-Eleven and put Seagram Seven
in a Slurpee cup and go back to work it
looked like we were drinking a bucket
Slurpee with Seagram Seven right and in
the pilot I said hey at lunch don't go
over and bring open those things and put
alcohol on and try to pretend it's a
Slurpee so I use the real thing and then
thirsties was the bar we went to there
was a Thursday's in Santa Monica which
was a that bar was right here a titty
bar that was down the street we used a
one but but I kept it all to where to
what was my life well around my that's
why me and my stand-up a lot of people
call me a marriage therapist right A lot
of people go man we come to your show
for therapy
so how do I but what if you're just
talking to your friends outside and and
you're like a therapist to your friends
outside that too yeah absolutely and
you're not a therapist but you're like a
dude that says oh my wife man she's
crazy my wife told me do what you do you
got to do this but we lived it in the
episode and then you go into the episode
right no I love that too no absolutely I
mean look if you're a marriage therapist
you're stuck but if you're a dude that
they come and see you and they say hey
man who's this dude I'll just tell you
about it right that he his wife is home
how come because of this and that ah you
know I speak wife you came in the right
place do this and then you go do it I've
also been smart enough in my career to
know what I don't know and I've always
been able to take somebody like George
who's now on what show number four and
go well this guy knows the [__] he's
talking about I'm willing to listen and
learn from somebody that has already
gone through the process with by the way
Bruce Halford who's a [__] genius so
yeah I would love to show you the script
and then have you go ah let's do this
let's do that so that's what a producer
does you know you know when I in the 90s
when Drew Carey was doing his show with
Bruce Halford the old time days
I would tell Anna Drew K was like number
one on ABC and I would tell and where's
my Bruce Alford like I would be like
what the [__] you know where's my Bruce
Alford two people that I wanted only two
people that I wanted to work with and do
shows with one was Bruce we did the
first show and he's involved in this
show and the other one was Matt Williams
who did Home Improvement and worked on
and worked on Bill Cosby and Matt
Williams is a [__] genius he retired
he lives back up in York but that guy
is incredibly smart TV I did Saint
George with him and uh and he I read for
him at Disney on a Friday night around
seven o'clock and he was nice to me and
went to his office I didn't get the part
it was for Home Improvement I didn't get
the part and he was nice to me I left
and I remembered man that guy is [__]
great that little beige all sweater like
a like a cardigan had his own so you
know they have money sweats the whole
thing and uh those two guys that did the
show with so it's impo it's it's
everything is possible everything's
possible and it can come out of nowhere
like I didn't I didn't have this idea
for this show Debbie Debbie did so minus
Tick Tock yeah and did that where I
don't know if you remember I was with
you opening at Cap City in Austin and
you were like I gotta go Sandra's
picking me up and we're I'm gonna go
hang out with Sandra Bullock and I was
like holy [__] and at that time she was
dating uh Bob Schneider the musician
that's right and and George is like
later puto and I'm like
that's right you know but it was so cool
it was so cool to to see all of that
happening for you but as much as people
tell me wow you've made it right they
tell me that oh you're doing so great I
don't feel that
I feel this I thought you were content
I'm happy in my family I'm happy with my
marriage I'm happy with the roof over my
head and making money but I don't I I
have this fire inside me to continue to
work if you were a baseball player would
you be happy only making it to the
Double A no I got to go to the pros you
got to get a thousand percent I deserve
to be there I deserve to be there a
thousand percent and when I go to
um next week I'm in [__] Reading PA
sold out and there's three other dates
in PA completely sold out and I'm
sitting there going oh look I deserve to
have that show I deserve to have that
more what day what day do you leave yeah
uh not till Monday morning or evening
Monday morning yeah
which by the way I just read for a movie
that you're in
um with Eva Longoria
you were already I think you're already
cast in it and I just read for it they
love me not for that part so maybe I'll
get another part so I'm excited about it
what part is it I was supposed to play
well the part I read for was Eva
Longoria's husband
and how come you didn't how come you're
not right for him I don't know we got a
note from CAA saying that we love him we
think he's great we think he's hilarious
we might have something else for him in
the movie we don't think he's that guy
but that's been my whole career like I
can't tell you how many times I walk
into an audition and they go you're not
Mexican and I'm like what the [__] does
that mean
do you think that you should how could
you be Mexican you should put some I
need a [__] leaf blower what do I
need
but but again what would make how many
times I I I don't know that when you see
them do you see Mexican yeah
I'm gonna make a shirt because he has a
hickey oh this is my own shirt by the
way George you have your own shirts yep
okay you have to say what is that I got
something for you both you guys I'm
gonna send them out what is that on the
inside it's the wire better oh it's a
Mexican white batter with a western yolk
yeah it's my Tex-Mex shirt so says Trevi
on the back see that right there that's
yeah oh that's pretty cool yeah I got
them in black white pink boots yep boss
hello custom
all right you want a part of that movie
I'll call Marvin do you really love the
director or you read for it I I video I
did the video on it and sent it in so
they've already seen it I'd love to be
in that movie I I think my kid would
love to see me in that movie all right
uh it's a it's a good book too right
it's a great book and I had no idea I
told my wife I go I go I don't know what
this is and she goes you've read that
book and she showed me the book I'm like
oh my God I read that to my son all the
time yeah well not anymore he's seven
he's too cool now he's taking time let's
see if we could let's see if I can do
that that'd be fun it'll be fun
from Corpus I was already in it though
but but
it's a good it's an adapt it's adapted
from a kid's book yep that is a great
kids book yeah it's a great book
Alexander and a terrible day terrible
day
of Alexander and the guy Marvin who did
hentified is directing the big big movie
for him well Disney plus he's a Texas
guy right yes that's what I heard he's a
Texas guy and it's his first uh
directing part I don't know that so
let's see if I can get you in there well
they love me I think yeah well you never
know I mean look at [__] Trump Junior
over here they love me they all say it
yeah I'm great
um no I've learned and I think George
you probably feel the same way I do the
best I can and then I just leave it in
the past but have you have you taken
acting lessons I have taken acting
lessons with um Leslie Khan here in town
and my wife you know because she went to
Tish yeah yeah you know me and her are
always doing scenes because I started
taking it serious in the past few years
but comedians it can be good actor Rick
Gutierrez that dude did we did a movie
with that guy and he was he was very
good oh Rick how's he doing I haven't
talked on that guy in a million years
old
but but but I you know yeah you have
success but
like I think you would love it I think
you would love it well I think you would
love the opportunity I mean when I when
you go over there let's say you go over
there
and like
we'll talk about let me see about this
one so you go
in the morning somebody's waiting for
you go in there you have to do what you
do you rehearse they have to run through
today you'll run through tomorrow for
the network and the studio and this show
is good but then also you're surrounded
by good actors and they're good and you
let them be good and it's like today in
the morning you know we had some issues
with stuff and you know I brought the
actors together and and then they tell
me hey don't don't don't tell actors
anything you know you're riling them up
but they're not robots yeah and
I end up saying but look where we are
and look what time it is and look who we
are and we could be doing anything in
this in this town and here we are but
that comes down
yeah so you want a leader that right so
you can say they've done that whatever
we think we have issue wise are nothing
compared to the opportunity that we have
take a look around and you don't want to
destroy that because you can become the
guy who [__] about everything and I
didn't talk I told mine I said to
everybody a little comment here becomes
gets in the wind and then the studio
hears and the network hears and they
started you're a problem they start
going well what are they over there are
they working hard are they bitching
about everything that they not see the
opportunity or do they just want to
complain every week and that's how it
gets and we don't we don't want to be
people that complain every week ratings
are good all right and solid good good
I'm glad I I was and with peacock which
I'd have a streaming the first time so
they're good already like SWAT pizzas
but just how does that work do they add
both it comes on Friday and then it goes
to Peacock the next day and then when
it's on peacock it triples the ratings
that's how
they watch it on if I were to watch it
here and there's two million that watch
it here then there's three million that
watch seven million eight million that's
[__] awesome well you know and when I
watch them they're watching for the
young for Mayan and her boyfriend and
those and those things like dealing with
anxiety or dealing with this or not
speaking Spanish you have a kid that
doesn't speak Spanish so you so the
stories are of not necessarily about me
so much as they are about being younger
and then the grandson so I'm the anchor
but but the stories are really about
them I was I was impressed in in your
humility and and and the fact that you
were willing to play somebody that was
unsuccessful
that's you know when I watched the pilot
I was a little hesitant to all right
where's George going to go with this the
beginning of the show I'm like okay okay
couple great jokes boom boom that last
scene or the last what do they call it
the last I'm blanking out last act yeah
the last act when it all comes together
with you
being a cacapalos and your daughter
coming in and you admitting hey I have
[__] problems right that to me was
very admirable and and and got to be a
little bit hard for you to to be as as
successful as a man as you are
to be able to take a step back and go
okay I have to play somebody that's a
loser it's a little bit tough
and I think you know that with some with
some things that have was that your idea
or whose idea was that the idea was to
was to have it be about the years that
we didn't talk
and getting back to uh being in each
other's lives
but I would say that but it married a
little bit of your mind a little bit of
life being on the road and yes but also
I would say that
it's a little bit harder on my end than
that than the actual part of it I would
say but it works for it works for the TV
well and and I learned from actually
watching your daughter on Tick Tock that
you and your ex-wife have a great
relationship
ish
um I don't know man because on Tick Tock
she's always like they act like they're
not [__] married but they still act
like they're [__] right yeah yeah you
know so I also enjoyed the realism of
the ex-wife right being in it and and
the because at the end of the day it has
to have heart but you know that's right
and at the end of the day that's all you
have like when they take that show away
I mean Armani and I gonna be talking I
would hope so right and you know today I
walked her out or we walked after and
yeah it's not it you know you think when
you dream about a show that is
everything and it's it's something but
it's not everything but it's everything
you can get out of it but it still
shouldn't be everything like it
shouldn't be your whole life but it
should be part of your life but not
everything and in the beginning I
thought it was I thought it was
everything and I thought I was the boss
I wasn't and I thought it was a family
and it wasn't and I thought it was
um you know
it was it wasn't anything other than a
sitcom that with with people working on
the sitcom that have worked other shows
and they'd leave for a better offer so
you can't get glued to them or say hey I
don't want to do this show over here and
you go you know what I get it I told
mine hey we're like a family I said well
that's not true we're just get ready
they're working and let's do our work
and let's not make something that's not
let's just let everybody do their jobs
right and that's different from I
learned that from the first show where I
try to be [__] Willy Wonka make
everybody happy you can't make everybody
happy well and I told my wife I go the
one thing one of the reasons I want to
show is because I do deserve it and I've
worked hard for it and I think I have a
show I think you should have a chance at
it and I think I should have a chance at
it or not bad but I also want to miss
stand up
there's weeks where I [__] go and and
of course I perform and of course I give
the audience everything I have but but I
mean I know what you're gonna say but
Talent it is tough for people to it is
tough for a comedian to to be on that
it's hard man and and uh and there are
weeks where I'm like [__] another show
[__] man I'm just gonna go drink I can't
wait to get this show done because I'm
not at home I'm stuck in a [__] hotel
room I'm just gonna get smashed tonight
we call it blackout Friday because [__]
it I'm a blackout tonight because I'm
away from my fan I want to miss so when
I take a week off or two weeks off and I
get on that [__] stage the fire that
comes out of me the excitement and then
I'm on edge because I'm like oh [__] do
I remember my bits right and I'm a
little sharper so I I told my wife go
man a movie break or a TV show break so
that I could be creative in another way
yeah so that when I come back to stand
up I'm [__] Jazz have you ever done a
movie never done a movie never done a TV
show no but but that's also my fault I I
but also when I was 20 years in I'd
never done a TV or a movie or a a movie
or TV show right so I was 81.99 898 but
I had the same idea you had where I go
I'm gonna become a great stand-up right
that's my goal all my friends were over
there with [__] headshots and
auditioning commercials and and I'm over
there going no no no y'all go do that
I'm gonna get on stage you don't have to
say when you're good they'll find you
that's what I [__] say the same [__]
yeah I thought it was like the same for
football like you see players that come
out of these colleges or Scottie Pippen
came from like South Arkansas college if
you're a bad [__] if you're
funny they'll find you yep they'll find
you because they'll have to and it's
cool to get these phone calls and and
people reaching out going oh my God has
CAA done a good job you think I just got
with them okay uh so far so good that
you know they got me the audition for
for the movie uh the the movie that
you're already in
um there's another audition and I
probably can't say the name of it but
there's another audition they got me
which I'm but you know what I don't want
to see the script I want to see two
pages of what you think you have okay
like a treatment a tree that's all I
want to see I want to see the the the
premise yep and I think it's you and
your wife and the kids and friends
almost like King of Queens I see almost
like thousand I always say that I'm the
Latino Kevin James I think it's King of
Queens so let's see because also oh
the uh uh Dice Clay had a show bless his
house with Kathy Moriarty and dice Bruce
Alford did that show I don't know Bruce
did that and it came out and it was and
it was good it was really good but dice
was a comedian at that time and he
didn't understand the politics of the
sitcom and he didn't like Bruce he was
calling him names and this and that but
the show got off to a good start I
watched it it was called I remember
Bruce
and he was bitching the whole time
because he was a comedian and now you're
in a sitcom format but you're also in a
sitcom form with the dude that did
Roseanne yeah one of them and he was he
was a big show runner and then you're
degrading your show runner which I've
never done this person I assumed it I
saw him yesterday
gave a Christmas birthday present I
always tell people the smartest thing
ever happened to me was people told me I
was dumb you don't win the biggest
blessing so because if I feel dumb I go
tell me what to do tell me how to do
[__] bagging on Bruce talking about
the script the script ain't [__] it
ain't [__] until you film it so in the
beginning there's rewrites this and that
might not go the way you wanted he's
bitching and complaining but it's on the
air
he calls Les moonves up on the weekend
the president of CBS that's the last
Moon best and less moonves on Monday
cancels the show
because you don't call the president of
CBS in Malibu at his house wherever on
the weekend to complain about Bruce
Alford and and let's move it said well
maybe this Show's not worth having on
because you got this guy [__] calling
me at home well Rodney Carrington did
the same thing and they canceled it and
you know what show is just like bless
his house King of Queens no [__] well
Rodney Carrington did the same thing
he's got a show on the air and then he
just he was with me at ABC he was after
me he decided to get on
um Bob and Tom and [__] about ABC and
ABC was gay
we can't it's a huge opportunity yeah
and I always tell my agents you know I
go like a look guys I need that one
thing
that one [__] thing that's all I need
all right you know what Cheech told me
in like 99 she said
that you need to get that one thing
and once you get one thing you turn that
thing into another thing and then it's a
snowball and in 99 2000 I got bread and
roses that independent film about the
about the janitors in LA and I had the
part of this it was in 99 99 and then it
went to the Cannes Film Festival so the
first movie I did went to can
and then I call Cheech after I got it I
said I got the one thing and from that
one thing everything came after that
it's crazy from the one thing well then
Sandra's sister saw you right
um no she had a producer guy that I
still talked to uh but she came and saw
me
Sandra came and saw me at the improving
Brea and
um
like
August of 2001. I just go I just
remember
one minute George is in Dallas at the
Edison improv which is one of my
favorite rooms to this day yeah one of
my favorites of the day it's 320 seats
they'll tell you it's 250. that's a
whole nother yeah yeah but George
selling it out
and there was an energy about it yes
six months later they announced the show
George is doing the Majestic that's
right I go to The Majestic
and it was a whole nother [__] feel
it was it went from that's George Lopez
to holy [__] that's George Lopez and it
was in six months yep am I right yep it
was the most unbelievable fee and I I
loved it because I saw it at the Addison
Improv and then when I went to and you
let me open right you let me open and
then I started I was like holy sh this
is different
this is and again
you also people don't realize how
difficult Fame is
that's another thing that people don't
realize people don't realize how hard it
is
to I used to say man why do these
[__] guys leave the most and why the
[__] are they hiding in the green room
and and and man George came to the ice
house he didn't say hi to us he just
went straight to the Green Room now I
understand now I get it now I go well
[__] if you said hi to me then he's
stuck outside saying hi to [__]
everybody and then the guy can't go to
bed right the guy's gonna come to the
ice house and spend four [__] hours
yeah talking to people when he just
wants to do a show and go home right so
now I get it so it's taken a lot for me
to step into your shoes and understand
what you've been through and what you're
going through
right so yeah looking at your watch it's
different I know yeah
no no no no no no no no VHS tonight no
no no no no but every night I see Gil
watching this documentary but I mean
it's it's you know but there's a lot of
guys that get there and come back and of
all colors and I would see those guys at
the Laugh Factory like they would say
hey I got a development deal and they go
get they go get it and they come back
they're not even development deals
anymore you get an opportunity but
you have to have something prepared or
you're not even going to get a bite like
they're not going to write it's better
to have something for you than to them
think of something for you right I had a
guy that wrote on Cheers I think Dan
Shaughnessy or somebody like that that I
went to go meet at Paramount and and hit
the note back to my agents where he
doesn't write for Latinos
and I'm like what the [__] does that
mean like just right are we people is it
funny just right Bruce never said I
don't write for Latinos Bruce is like
whatever George writes down we'll work
around it and he even called Peter Robb
that President he said
you have to make this guy a Creator
because what I have is not what he's
giving us and he's giving us the whole
show and I don't feel right putting my
name as a Creator without because they
don't make first time
uh show guys right creators because
that's where the money is and they and
he fought for me to be a Creator and for
my points in the show and that's well
because you were I mean you were you
were that voice he said I'm not this
isn't me I can't this isn't this is him
the grandma the mom was my grandmother
the wife was my wife by the way best
friend what a brilliant cast with your
mom with your grandma well who played
your mom yes because amazing she was a
SMU Dallas theater actress phenomenal
actually went to went to school acted
incredible Tom Cruise trained amazing
amazing and a great person to be around
and then all Ernie was the dude from
blood and blood out that's right he was
the cholo from blood and blood solid
actor he was great in Erin Brockovich
that's right and he and even when the
show started since they were all kind of
actors they were a click in themselves
like they would go have lunch without me
like I would go to my room but they
would go have lunch and come back as a
click and then go back out as a click
and I was like all right these
[__] are like they're their
thing they're there it's that thing and
then they said
they said well you know you you can't
count on anything because this is TV and
we've had TV opportunities before so you
can't count anything I said you know
what the [__] you could count on this
let's do it I'll [__] tell you can
count on this we'll see
and it's just when we got picked up for
the for the back nine they never looked
back until we were done 120. we got we
got this one the back nine I would think
the same thing I would think that we're
not going to look back until we're over
a hundred let's knock it out knock it
out that's awesome and in that which I
didn't do the first time because I was
sick had kidney disease but in this time
I'm going to produce other shows like
those two girls that were in here Mary
Aaron the two girls that you can't tell
they want dick or not
yeah
I think they're my second thing but you
you never know and George says
you never know scissors or scissors I
mean if you saw it would you pull it or
would you repel who cares so who cares
so so they remember we told about the
show
Aaron didn't I probably don't give a
[__] he's a [__] bill bursts
but it's cool to see how magical on your
show yeah I mean there's a guy that's
that's doing big things in TV and movies
and he's I mean all things comedy it's
all [__] ow man the guy's this guy's
a monster so is he doing things is he
doing big things in movies
yeah he was a cop in in morbius yep
he was he was uh uh Ben Affleck sidekick
and um the way back yeah
to [__] Blockbusters did you see
those no
I know I'm kidding but that was amazing
but but also those two girls that they
met here and they were from the same
area they didn't know they didn't know
each other remember that's something to
go go right yeah
they wrote a script and I sent it to the
girl from from Blue Beetle Melissa
because she's in that age and she said
they're amazing and this script is funny
I think we can sell that one they just
did it
about living in uh Charleston yeah and
they did Virginia everybody that comes
in here I say I'm gonna I'm gonna help
him but I'm going to help you well love
it okay do you do the treatment and I'm
gonna call Marvin about the about the
movie yeah absolutely man look again you
know I my journey
and we talked a long time ago about
something we didn't agree about but I
called you and we worked it out
absolutely and again you know I
it's hard to understand when you're not
in the shoes
you know and I've always said this about
you there's nobody ever going to be
funnier than you when it comes to
Chicano humor that that's there's nobody
however I've always felt just like the
black community that we need to be
represented everything that it means to
be uh Latino in this country right you
know and I was talking I don't be gross
I don't have the uh I don't have the uh
like the the template of Chicano humors
like it's what humorous humor whatever
humorous humor and and your life is your
life and my life is my life you know and
I always tell people look man I grew up
with a solid Vietnam vet father
hard-working mother we you know we were
never on welfare we were never I mean we
didn't have big house but you know my my
perspective on my life is very different
than yours I think his dad is a
conspiracy theorist on his show oh he's
coming over let me tell you what
happened Nicole they go oh did you hear
about this is that what they told it is
they're testing people man they're
cutting parts of people's necks out and
testing them you'll see yeah there's a
chip in the coven vaccine there's that
champion
you know when that character walks in
the room
that's right they're gonna hit a home
run yeah so like Everybody Loves Raymond
like the brother I think I think you
look at it like that and I think you
just make it a treatment
and things get bought on treatments
absolutely and and look we're at a point
now where if it's good people are gonna
fight that's right and there's there's a
million ways to find it and they will
find it and and you have to be yeah I
mean who would have [__] thought
Paramount plus would have Yellowstone
one of the biggest shows amazing but the
bigger show on TV biggest show on TV
people found it yeah you know and is it
simple do you watch Yellowstone yes I do
uh you watch all of them um all of them
is it good you watch it it's a great
show it's it's I always say it's uh it's
Sons of Anarchy on horses
okay which shows better The Sopranos or
son of energy Sopranos which shows
better Yellowstone or Sons of Anarchy
for me Yellowstone Yellowstone whoa is
Yellowstone better than The Sopranos no
no I would have to agree
that's the problem uh Tim doesn't do
anything Tim doesn't watch anything yeah
surprise is great great show and and
Sopranos I love Beth but but Yellowstone
is is Beth is a sushi in Yellowstone oh
she's badass oh yeah
yeah and you know what's weird about
that she kicks ass she played she played
um Costner's sister in Draft Day
and now she plays his daughter and the
guy Cole Hauser rip wheeler whatever
that guy's name is call Hauser from days
they're confused Cole house has been
around forever forever since days are
confused huge start she come up with a
line in front of Kevin Costner that's
her dad sit there says what do we have
to I remember the time that the first
time I told you about when I was
involved in a threesome now what kind of
daughter goes up and tells her old man
what's it what's the premise of
Yellowstone [__] I don't know it's it is
it is literally Sons of Anarchy with
horses this guy owns this Ranch and
everybody's coming into town to take his
[__] Ranch from the the Indians the
the Native Americans want it back and
all the developers are coming into
Montana to take it from him and he
[__] fights them all off and kills
all them [__] killing people oh
yeah take him to the train station
can you get away with killing people but
again but again how are there no Latinos
on horses over there but what every
Ranch I've been to there's [__]
Mexicans on horses
Mexicans are the horses they carry the
[__] people in their backs I don't
worry about stuff like that you know I I
really don't I if it's good it's good
it's good we don't worry about stuff
like that you don't give a [__] you go
to a restaurant
I'm 73 [__] years old how many years
left do I have to worry about [__] like
that probably two hey if it's irritating
if it's interesting
so you don't overthink it you're just
like no I just watch it and accept it
for what it is I like the uh they did
the 1882 which was the
prequel yeah they're doing the the
Yellowstone is one of those if you watch
if I want I haven't watched any of them
and I did uh Jimmy Fallon the same day I
did the Today show with Cole Hauser yeah
and when he walked in all of your
husband were like oh red I always say
I'm lower case rip
that little baby rip
them
I enjoy it
my wife uh I'm gonna watch he likes it
she's in love with rip I'm in love with
Beth Beth Beth she's a bad [__] right
she's a fast
yes she does and she talks so much [__]
dude she's a fighter the fighter brought
out hey come let's go outside do they
torture her and she don't give a [__]
hits out there and throws how much land
does this guy have thousands of acres
and they want it oh yeah it's right
right outside of building who created
this the yellow uh Taylor Sheldon
Sheridan who was on matter of fact he
was on the Sons of Anarchy they just
announced oh that's a house that they
use the Dunn residents that they really
use in Montana you can rent it
if you want to thank you 36 000 a night
yeah
you can rent the house but it's not in
Montana right yeah because I know they
shoot a lot in Utah yeah this it's there
the land they give you people to work at
everything takes 36 000 a night and then
the dude's doing a spin-off in Texas
with a triple six round the I mean like
this guy's wow it's [__] unbelievable
he's like Shonda Rhimes I don't know who
that is so she did uh all the which ones
Gray's Anatomy and all the other ones
paid entertaining I love you thanks for
coming by man man it was a pleasure
talking to you George yeah there's still
a lot more to talk about absolutely and
and I just man I I just love the history
and the things that you've done and
accomplished man and it's all it's all
well deserved and sir you have made it
and you are cheating on it
let's see let's see what we can do man
let's see uh let's start with that movie
but
you know we'll figure it out and then
we'll go to the idea for the show but I
think I said I'll help you out with that
one too you got it man thank you Gail
pleasure meeting my friends pleasure
meeting you I'm the [__] yeah I'm
glad I don't have to worry about all
this [__] you know